a cyclist crosses an intersection
without looking well the driver applied
the brakes in time it doesn't matter
because the car will stop itself
a vehicle is parked on a highway a panic
stop may not be enough to avoid a
collision the only solution is to swerve
around it by using the neighboring lane
the car an experimental vehicle from
setup friedrichshafen AG performed the
maneuver on its own vision zero is all
about a promise a commitment in the
future to pursue a time when there will
be zero accidents and there will be zero
emissions associated with personal
mobility and by on the road then you can
see it today we're in the test track
today and you're gonna see tangible
steps tangible examples of technology
that contribute towards that long-term
objective these are the initial steps
that we're taking as a company the
component supplier said EPS bases near
Lake Constance it's loaded up a car with
lots of visionary technology including
active seat belts that tighten when the
going gets rough an intelligent
operating concept and even new driving
assistant functions car tested Montes
kirat says there are plenty of signs
ahead said app development engineer
johannes processes that's the point
Martha says the route is clear but
Johannes says people do enter highways
going in the wrong direction and the car
is fitted out with sensors in an
extremely precise location system it
knows the way and which direction to
take if we try to drive up the highway
entrance ramp going the wrong way
Martha sees the warning on the display
that engineer says first there's a
visual warning then a signal from the
steering wheel once you begin going the
wrong way the car slows itself down it
could be a one-way street or something
less dangerous than a highway at some
point the car decides to come to a full
stop
Johannes says more functions could be
added an emergency call or directions to
resolve the situation while avoiding for
the risks
mouth to the Huns if I'm riding every
here in Germany alone there are more
than 2,000 cases of wrong-way driving on
highways the system could help reduce
those numbers
distraction is another cause of
accidents with some drivers looking at
their smartphones rather than keeping
their eye on the road the developers
have built-in assistant systems for
these threats to a camera recognizes
where the driver is looking in an
emergency it takes over to avoid
collisions or other types of accidents
and if the driver is given up steering
entirely the car takes over that -
Johanna says there are buttons on the
steering wheel that let you see when the
car is ready to take over control a
driver then activates the entire system
and lets the car drive itself a montes
is amazed noting that the car does it
all very smoothly
Johannes tells him that the speed is set
to limit lateral acceleration with the
aim of keeping driver and passenger
comfortable autonomous driving is
supposed to free and decouple the driver
from the job of driving then he's a
passenger and driving should feel as
smooth as possible imagine reading a
paper or doing something else you don't
want to be getting bounced around the
whole time that's why when we get to the
bumps the car will change lanes smoothly
with the help of its rear steering
meaning the car won't rotate on its
vertical axis let's check it out what is
ass if there's built-in rear axle
steering yes says Johannes we're still
looking straight ahead and feel a bit of
lateral acceleration that's unavoidable
but when you're in the back and look
down it's much more comfortable
they've put similar technology in
another car the Ford f-150 isn't exactly
known for its maneuverability it's more
likely to drive over the cones then
around them there's an assist for that
too mother says bigger cars can be
problematic and nowadays all cars are
bigger and the Ford f-150 is one of the
bigger ones of those what happens when
you have to go down a narrow road going
into a parking garage for example or
driving on a course he says there's no
way this car can do it all trooped
garnished super vaiting is that how
should I go with a car which is about I
don't know 25,000 meters long yeah how
should I go through this with the
wonderful thing is with our AKC system
we give you 12 degrees of rear steer
angle on the rear so it brings our turn
circle down from what this f150 would be
down to what would be the Ford Kuga he's
not so sure so he's going to see for
himself and we can give it a try
yes at first the test seems almost
impossible no this seems to be very very
narrow here it would be would be without
without rooster mother says if you look
at the course it seems really narrow
driving through it is a real challenge
yet the enormous steering angle makes it
all is easiest child's play there are
already cars with systems like this but
the steering angle is much smaller ZF
wants to use the f-150 to show what the
technology can do the six meter long
pickup can be steered through the cones
effortlessly it's turning radius drops
from fourteen point six to eleven point
six meters
as a mother says he thought it would
have been impossible but you can
actually do the course in this big car
thanks to the added rear axle steering
that moves the rear wheels 12 degrees as
well it's gravy says we go back to the
car that's got all the new systems on it
Mozza sums up a day that's been full of
surprises
[Music]
the vision zero is really exciting it's
shown impressively the way in which
driving is likely to develop in the next
10 or 15 years whether assist systems
are involved or it's completely
autonomous and the whole steering thing
that's really outrageous